one way to learn the parameters of the
neural network so that it gives you a
good encoding for your pictures of faces
is to define and apply gradient descent
on the triplet loss function let's see
what that means to apply the triplet
loss you need to compare pairs of images
for example given this picture to learn
the parameters of the neural network you
have to look at several pictures at the
same time for example given this pair of
images you want their encodings to be
similar because these are the same
person
whereas given this pair of images you
want their encodings to be quite
different because these are different
persons in the terminology of the
triplet loss what you're going to do is
always look at one anchor image and then
you want the distance between the anchor
and a positive image really a positive
example meaning is the same person to be
similar whereas you want the anchor when
pairs are compared to the negative
example for their distances to be much
further apart so this is what gives rise
to the term triplet loss which is that
you always be looking at three images at
a time you'll be looking at an anchor
image a positive image as well as a
negative image and I'm going to
abbreviate anchor a positive and
negative as a P and N so to formalize
this what you want is for the parameters
of your neural network or for your
encodings to have the following property
which is that you want the encoding
between the anchor - the encoding of the
positive example you want this to be
small and in particular you want this to
be less than or equal to the distance or
the squared norm between the encoding of
the anchor and the encoding of the
negative where of course this is d of a
P and this is d of a and
and you can think of D as a distance
function which is why we named it with
the alphabet D now if we move the term
from the right side of this equation to
the left side what you end up with is f
of a minus F of P squared minus when I
take the right hand side now minus F of
N squared you want this to be less than
or equal to zero but now we're going to
make a slight change to this expression
which is one trivial way to make sure
this is satisfied is to just learn
everything equals zero if F always
outputs 0 then this is 0 minus 0 which
is 0 this is 0 minus 0 which is 0 and so
well by saying F of any image equals a
vector of all zeros you can you know
almost trivially satisfy this equation
so to make sure that the neural network
doesn't just output 0 for all the
encoding so to make sure that it doesn't
set all the encoding 's equal to another
each other right another way for the
neural network to give a trivial output
is if the encoding for every image was
identical to the encoding to every other
image in which case you again get 0 0
minus 0 so to prevent in your network
from doing that what we're going to do
is modify this objective to say that
this doesn't need to be just less than
or equal to 0 it needs to be quite a bit
smaller than 0 so in particular we say
this needs to be less than negative
alpha where alpha is another hyper
parameter then this prevents the new
network from outputting the trivial
solutions and by convention usually we
write plus alpha instead of negative
alpha there and this is also called a
margin which is terminology that you'd
be familiar with if you've also seen the
literature on support vector machines
but don't worry about it if you haven't
and we can also modify this equation on
top by adding this margin parameter so
say we give an example let's say the
margin is set to zero point two if in
this example D of the anchor and the
positive is equal to 0.5 then you won't
be satisfied of D between the anchor and
the negative was just a little bit
bigger say 0.5 1 right even though 0.5 1
is bigger than 0.5 you're saying that's
not good enough we want D of a common
end to be much bigger than D of a tamo P
and in particular you want this to be at
least 0.7 or higher or alternatively to
achieve this margin or this gap of at
least zero point two you could either
push this up or push this down so that
there is this at least this gap of this
alpha hyper parameter alpha at 0.2
between the distance between the anchor
and the positive versus the anchor and
the negative so that's what having a
margin parameter here does which is it
pushes the anchor positive pair and the
anchor negative here further away from
each other so let's take this equation
we have here at the bottom and on the
next slide formalize it and define the
Triplett loss function so the Triplett
loss function is defined on triples of
images so given three images a P and n
the anchor positive and negative
examples so the positive examples is of
the same person as the anchor but the
negative is of a different person than
the anchor we're going to define the
loss as follows the loss on this example
which is really defined on a triplet of
images is let me first copy over what we
had on the previous slide so that was um
FA minus F P squared minus F
a minus F N squared and then plus alpha
the margin parameter and what you want
is for this to be less than or equal to
zero so to define the loss function
let's take the max between this and zero
so the effect of taking the max here is
that so long as this is less than zero
then the loss is zero because the max of
something less than equal to 0 with 0 is
going to be 0 so so long as you achieve
the goal of making this thing of
underlined in green so long as you've
achieved the objective of making that
less than or equal to zero then the loss
on this example is equal to zero but if
on the other hand if this is greater
than zero then if you take the max the
max who end up selecting this thing of
underline and green and so you would
have a positive loss so by trying to
minimize this this has the effect of
trying to send this thing to be zero or
less than equal to zero and then so long
as this zero or less than equal to zero
the neural network doesn't care how much
further
negative negative it is so this is how
you define the loss on a single triplet
and the overall cost function for your
neural network can be sum over a
training set of these individual losses
on different Triplets so if you have a
training set of say 10,000 pictures with
a thousand different persons what you
have to do is take your 10,000 pictures
and use it to generate to select
triplets like this and then train your
learning algorithm using gradient
descent on this type of cost function
which is really defined on Triplets of a
of images drawn from your training set
notice that in order to define this data
set of triplets
you do need some pairs of a and P pairs
of pictures of the same person so the
purpose of training your system you do
need a data sets where you
of multiple pictures of the same person
that's why in this example I said if you
have 10,000 pictures of 1000 different
persons so maybe you have ten pictures
on average of each of you 1000 persons
to make up you entire dataset if you had
just one picture of each person then you
can't actually train this system but of
course after training if you're applying
this but of course after having trained
this system you can then apply it to
your one-shot learning problem where for
your face recognition system maybe you
have only a single picture of someone
you might be trying to recognize but for
your training set you do need to make
sure you have multiple images of the
same person at least for some people in
your training set so that you can have
pairs of anchor and positive images now
how do you actually choose these
triplets to form your training set one
of the problems with if you choose a P
and n randomly from your training set
subject to a and P being the same person
and in n being different persons one of
the problems is that if you choose them
sort of at random then this constraint
is very easy to satisfy because given
two randomly chosen pictures of people
chances are a and n are much different
than a and P well and I hope you still
recognize this notation does D AP was
what we have written on the last few
slides as these encoding so this is just
equal to this squared norm distance
between the encoding is that we had on
the previous line but if a and n are two
randomly chosen different persons then
there's a very high chance that this
will be much bigger more than the margin
alpha then that term on the left and so
the neural network won't learn much from
it so to construct your training set
what you want to do is to choose
triplets a P and n that are hard to
train on so in particular what you want
is for all triplets that this constraint
be satisfied
so a triplet that is hard would be of
you choose values for a P and n so that
maybe D AP is actually quite close to D
am so in that case the learning
algorithm has to try extra hard to tick
this thing on the right and try to push
it up or take this thing on the left and
try to push it down too so that there is
at least a margin of alpha between the
left side and the right side and the
effect of choosing these triplets is
that it increases the computational
efficiency of your learning algorithm if
you choose the triplets randomly then
too many triplets would be really easy
and so gradient descent won't do
anything because you knew Network will
just get them right pretty much all the
time and is only by choosing hard
triplets that the gradient descent
procedure has to do some work to try to
push these quantities further away from
those quantities and if it interested
the details are presented in this paper
by Florence chef Dimitri colony chenko
and James Hoban where they have a system
called phase net which is where a lot of
the ideas are presenting in this video
had come from by the way this is also a
fun fact about how algorithms are often
named in the deep learning world which
is if you work on a certain domain let
me call that blank you often have a
system called blank net or deep blank so
we've been talking about face
recognition so this paper is called face
net and in the last video you just saw
deep face but this idea of a blank net
or deep blank is a very popular way of
naming algorithms in the deep learning
world and you should feel free to take a
look at that paper if you want to learn
some of these other details for speeding
up your algorithm by choosing the most
useful triplets to train on it is a nice
paper so just a wrap up to train on
triplet loss you need to take your
training set and map it to a lot of
triples so here is a triple with an
anchor and a positive both are the same
pair
negative of a different person here's
another one where the anchor and
positive are the same person
but the anchor and negative are verdant
persons and so on and what you do having
to find this training set of anchor
positive and negative triples is used
gradient descent to try to minimize the
cost function J we defined on an earlier
slide and that will have the effect of
back propagating to all the parameters
of the neural network in order to learn
an encoding so that D of two images will
be small when these two images are of
the same person and they'll be large
when these are two images of different
persons so that's it for the triplet
loss and how you can train a neural
network for learning and encoding for
face recognition now it turns out that
commercial face recognition systems are
trained on fairly large data sets at
this point often north of a million
images sometimes not infrequently north
of ten million images and there's some
commercial companies talking about using
over a hundred million images so these
are very large data sets by moderns that
even buy so that's it for the triplet
loss and how you can use it to train a
neural network to output a good encoding
for face recognition now it turns out
that today's face recognition systems
especially the large-scale commercial
face recognition systems are trained on
very large data sets david says north of
a million images is not uncommon some
companies are using north of ten million
images and some companies have north of
a hundred million images with which to
try to train these systems so these are
very large data sets even by modern
standards these data set asses are not
easy to acquire fortunately some of
these companies have trained these large
networks and posted parameters online so
rather than trying to train one of these
networks from scratch this is one domain
where because of the sheer data volume
sizes this is one domain where often it
might be useful for you to download
someone else's free training model
rather than to everything from scratch
yourself but even if you do download
someone else's pre-trained model I think
it's so useful to know how these
algorithms were trained in case you need
to apply these ideas from scratch
yourself for some application so that's
it for the triplet loss in the next
video I want to show you also some other
variations on siamese networks and how
to train G systems let's go onto the
next video